whether it's an x-men film the next
chapter in the MCU or an entry in the DC
extended universe superhero movies are
filled with some truly incredible
moments these films are about
super-powered beings who fight crime
serve justice and provide humanity with
hope as a result they've given us all
kinds of epic moments and stunning
visuals that'll make you want to slam
that pause button it all started in 2008
when Tony Stark announced I am Iron Man
after that we were introduced to a green
rage monster a star-spangled soldier the
god of thunder and two deadly assassins
but we hadn't seen them all together yet
until the Avengers came along directed
by Joss Whedon this 2012 mega hit
assembled Earth's Mightiest Heroes for
the very first time they bickered that
bantered they battled aliens and every
scene built towards possibly the
greatest hero shot in cinematic history
in the final act of the film Loki and
his cheat are er me are attacking New
York City five of the six Avengers are
doing their best to hold back the aliens
but then there's a toothy space whale
that joins the fray fortunately that's
when a bit draggled Bruce Banner shows
up he gets mad Hulk smashes the
Leviathan and the angry Chitauri
surround the Avengers letting loose with
a terrifying war cry but these heroes
aren't afraid instead they all stand
back-to-back preparing for war
as the camera circles around them and
you'll need to press pause so you can
fully revel in such an awesome moment
black panther introduced the world to
kill monger possibly the greatest
villain to wreak havoc in the MCU played
by Michael B Jordan he's a black ops
soldier who wants the wakandan throne
but before he can rule he must defeat
King T'Challa even though it's
incredibly advanced nation Wakanda still
practices ritual combat if you beat the
king you get the crown and kill monger
has been training his entire life for
this as his name implies he's been
racking up an impressive body count and
every time he takes a life he marks his
body with a scar at first we only see a
few bumps on his forearm but when it
comes time to fight to chala
he pops off that shirt and reveals he's
absolutely covered in little dots
according to Jordan there were over
2,000 of those bumps which heads up to a
lot of corpses
it's a terrific and terrifying reveal
showing that kill monger is going to be
the toughest
challenge that T'Challa has ever faced
on top of that scene kill monger in all
his glory prompted quite a bit of thirst
from Michael B Jordan fans every time I
think about Michael B Jordan my uterus
combust into the airport battle and
Captain America Civil War might be the
greatest comic book movie moment of all
time all these heroes are coming
together for an epic showdown nobody
wants to kill anyone and they're mostly
friends so they're going to exchange as
many quips as kicks still that doesn't
stop them from shooting arrows tossing
cars and blowing things up as a result
you've got a fun-filled action scene
filled with pause worthy moments that
need some extra appreciation for example
there's the first appearance of the MCU
snoo spider-man the moment that giant
man snags war machine out of the air at
any time that black panther is going to
town but the scene that deserves the
most attention comes in both groups
finally square off when it becomes clear
that caps team isn't backing down the
two groups rush at each other for a
superhero extravaganza as the Avengers
battle each other in this melee of epic
proportions the pause button will come
in handy if you want to see who fights
whom how they're using their powers
who's the toughest hero in this crazy
Civil War when you're playing the Joker
you've got to make a big entrance and on
that score it's hard to compete with
Heath Ledger's strange and scary intro
in the Dark Knight one of the best
opening scenes of all time a gang of
robbers all wearing clown masks it's one
of the biggest banks in Gotham but as
they deactivate the alarm system and
crack the safe you hear them talking
about their murderous and mysterious
employer the Joker the clown thieves
whisper about how the Joker wears war
paint and how he's totally crazy he's
also quite dangerous as he's ordered the
robbers to pick each other off one by
one eventually there's only one clown
left and he's about to make his big
getaway when he hears somebody screaming
after him it's the bank manager and he's
none too impressed with these mask
wearing thugs and that's when we get the
money shot the clown gets in the bank
managers face and pulls off his mask to
reveal that yes indeed he is the Joker
he's got greasy hair darkened eyes and
big scars it's then that you'll want to
pause the film so you can admire that
impeccably choreographed heist and also
so that you can calm down after staring
straight into the eyes of chaos Tony
Stark has always been the most
complicated Avenger but when he first
appeared in 2008
man he was a straight-up jerk he was
completely self-centered and immoral and
he made his living as a merchant of
death he sold weapons of mass
destruction and until he was captured by
terrorists he doesn't care where his
missiles ended up despite all of this
his obnoxious attitude gave us one of
the most pause worthy moments in the MCU
when he proudly presents is Jericho
missiles ever the showman Tony gives a
razzle-dazzle speech to a group of army
officers as he fires his weapon into an
Afghani desert the missile opens midair
and sends a dozen tiny rockets tumbling
down into the mountains below as they
ignite some massive explosions Tony
spreads his arms like a circus
ringmaster and it's here that you'll
want to press pause the smoke is
billowing in the background the
shockwave is heading straight for the
camera and Tony's hubris is on full
display director Christopher Nolan has a
knack for creating truly staggering
visuals and one of the most breathtaking
is the burning bat symbol in the Dark
Knight Rises this 2012 flick finds
Gotham City in a world of trouble the
villainous bane has taken over and he's
holding everybody hostage with a neutron
bomb he's cut off all escape routes
trapped the police in the sewer system
and worse still he recently broke
Batman's back and tossed him into an
underground prison things are looking
grim for the citizens of Gotham
especially Commissioner Gordon who's
about to get iced and that's when Batman
shows up to save the day you can't keep
a good bat down and after Batman fixes
his back and escapes the pit he rescues
Gordon from his incredibly cold fate but
the rest of the city needs to know help
is on the way so the two crime fighter's
light a giant flaming bat symbol atop a
nearby bridge the burning logo gives
everyone hope and it's such a powerful
shot that it's worth pausing the film to
admire the flames Hugh Jackman joined
the x-men in 2000 and he proceeded to
play the cigar-chomping Wolverine for
over 16 years
in fact he holds the Guinness world
record for longest career as a
live-action Marvel superhero along with
his x-men co star Patrick Stewart so
when it came time for Jackman to say
goodbye in Logan it broke a lot of
Marvel fans hearts fortunately the 2017
film gave the character a proper goodbye
he went out fighting protecting the
children from an evil band of scientists
and soldiers he was sent off with one of
cinema's most emotional eulogies with
tears welling in her eyes the young
Laura stands over Logan's grave and
delivers a monologue from the classic
western film Shane everything was all
right after the speech she reaches over
to Logan's grave marker and flips it on
its side turning a cross into an X you
want to hit the pause button here
because the tears will be flowing and
you'll also want to marvel at that final
shot of the grave a tender farewell to
the most famous of the x-men
ever since the credits of the first
Avengers film Marvel fans Knuth anos was
coming the mad Titan finally made his
move in Avengers infinity war rounding
up all the Infinity stones and having
the population of the universe with a
single snap but before that
heartbreaking moment the Avengers did
their best to stop the purple warlord
and none were quite as effective as
Doctor Strange the surgeon turned
sorcerer was a key player in infinity
war protecting the time stone from the
Black Order and battling Thanos himself
on Titan and it's on this desolate
planet that strangest powers are on full
display the opens portals for spider-man
to jump through he helps star-lord run
through the air and his cloak even gets
in on the action in fact the best moment
of the Titan fight is when strange and
Thanos go mano-a-mano the most pause
where the image comes with strange
sprouts multiple arms to perform the
images of icon you'll want to hit pause
again when there are about 100 dr.
Strange's attacking Thanos with 100
eldritch whips basically any time
strange and Thanos are throwing down
you'll want to pause the movie and
admire the magic as played by gal gadot
Wonder Woman aka Diana Prince was both
kind and courageous gentle and deadly
she was a compassionate God killer and
we got to see both sides on display
during one of the greatest action scenes
in superhero history the Battle of
no-man's land during a mission to stop
an evil German general Diana learns that
a village full of innocence has been
captured by enemy troops putting our
mission on hold
she decides to rescue the helpless
villagers by walking across the most
dangerous stretch of ground on the
western front with the help of her boy
proof bracelets she storms across
no-man's land blocking shots and
deflecting bombs like it's an afternoon
stroll through the park as Diana walks
through explosions and streaks of flame
you'll need to press the pause button
multiple times to fully absorb her
awesomeness
there's the scene where she steps onto
the battlefield in her full Wonder Woman
regalia there's the moment when she
blocks the first bullet and then there's
the scene when she pulls out that shield
and stops a barrage of machine gun
blasts it's maybe the most inspirational
seen in any DC movie and anytime you
press pause it can't help but stare in
wonder in the 2018 animated film
spider-man into the spider verse there's
no scene more visually impressive than
the moment Miles Morales finally takes a
leap of faith throughout the film this
teenager has been struggling with way
more than any kid should ever have to
deal with he suddenly gotten superpowers
but he doesn't know how to use them and
he's scared he might never live up to
his potential on top of all that there
are supervillains trying to kill him
which never makes things easier
grappling with his dual identities Miles
finally owns his spider persona adapting
a suit to fit his own background in
personality before literally taking a
leap off an enormous skyscraper as miles
free falls through the air he passes
through a gorgeous cityscape lit with
neon blues
dark purples and smooth pinks he's
directly at the center of the frame
surrounded by giant hulking buildings
the world seems so big Miles seems so
small and he's falling so fast but when
he blasts those web-shooters and begins
swinging through the city he is
spider-man he's done more than enough to
earn the cover to his own comic and this
scene has done more than enough to earn
a few admiring pauses check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]